[Music]
have you ever wondered which kaiju is
the biggest
there have been many that have crossed
the 100 meters height benchmark
and some even touching 150 meters tall
of course godzilla earth
comes to mind since he was more than 300
meters or a thousand feet tall
as well as his arch rival the
trans-dimensional ghidorah
which would easily take the first place
as he was tens of kilometers long
but ghidorah in this form is kind of
ethereal and intangible
so let us get past this one and look at
another kaiju that was far bigger than
even godzilla earth
and this one only appeared in the idw
comics godzilla rulers of earth
and the final issue relatively unknown
this alien kaiju dwarfed the rest of the
monsters of earth
making them look tiny in comparison
majita is the name of the giant trilobot
kaiju that was featured in the final
issue of godzilla rulers of earth
well what are these parts they are a
species of power absorbing alien
creatures which first appeared
in issue 19 of those comics they are the
first completely new major monsters to
appear in any of idw's godzilla comic
series
they are ultimate biological weapons of
the cry of aliens and these
triloports were deployed to earth to
conquer and subdue it
these vicious creatures proved more than
a match for earth's kaiju
stealing their powers and gradually
trapping them within a colossal hive in
los angeles
the tripods managed to even bring down
godzilla himself
the triloport's general physical
appearance is much like that of real
arthropods
these tripods have trilobite-like shells
and belly flaps
lined with sharp teeth and radial mouths
and sharp arm-like
sights with red spheres while all the
base trailer ports share common features
the beta teleports are taller than their
alpha counterparts
and stand upright mostly so that they
can fight other kaiju using their
massive sights but the most outstanding
feature is their ability to absorb and
mimic the powers
and appearances of other kaijus while
most of these alpha and beta types of
the tripods can
mimic and reach the sizes of other kaiju
there is one king called majita that was
bigger
than everything else in the entire
continuity majita is very similar in
appearance to its beta trilogy brethren
but it is considerably more massive and
completely dwarves godzilla and his
allies
majita possesses several more paddy pops
on its head than the other trailer ports
as well as dozens of circular glowing
patches on the sides of its neck
majita's arms are very long and are
tipped with sharp spikes
it was also named the trailer god or the
king of the trello ports
magetta did not display any notable
abilities during its sole appearance
however due to its incredible size it is
able to withstand all physical attacks
from other kaiju
and swat its enemies about with ease but
it was completely destroyed when
godzilla unleashed a nuclear pulse
from inside its mouth well let's look
into its size
even though an exact measurement of its
height was never released
this trailer guard is easily one of the
largest kaiju in the godzilla franchise
if not the largest standing many times
taller than godzilla and the other
monsters
it fought according to the main artist
for godzilla rulers of earth
matt frank magita is roughly the same
size as the magnetic monster from
the hannah barbara godzilla cartoon at
its maximum height which
stood several times godzilla's height
when asked about magetta's height
in comparison to the 300 meter tall
godzilla earth
he said that vegeta is 500 meters tall
while chris mori another one
stated that vegeta was at least eight
times the size of biollante
so around 960 meters in height by those
statements we can see that vegeta was
almost twice as tall as godzilla earth
if we take matt frank's statement and
more than three times taller if we go by
chris morris estimate
that would mean that the monsters of
earth were standing at its feet
no wonder they were not able to
physically harm it and only godzilla's
ultimate nuclear pulse inside its mouth
was able to finally defeat this titanic
kaiju otherwise its armor was
impenetrable
and none of the earth's kaiju's attacks
and even space godzilla
had any effect on it by the way in this
battle
both godzilla and space godzilla arched
enemies of each other
were forced to fight together against
the trilobots
now if some of you are still thinking as
to how the trailer ports absorb power
and how they were able to mimic the
monsters then let me finish
this video with this there are two types
of strider ports
other than magetta there are the smaller
alpha trailer ports which were six
legged and crawl on the ground
then there are the beta teleports which
stood by peel and were bigger in size
the ability to absorb power and
transform is a two-stage process
involving both trilobots first and alpha
must pierce the skin of a kaiju
to absorb its energy then climb onto the
back of a beta transport
and merge with it the resulting creature
will have both the powers and physical
characteristics of the target kaiju
this includes energy attacks like
godzilla's atomic breath and even space
godzilla's telekinesis and crystal
generation
and so with that we come to the end of
the video about the triloports and the
biggest kaiju majita
which was again way bigger than godzilla
earth like comparing a dog with a rhino
so subscribe and hit that bell button
for regular notifications
on our future videos take care fam